foreign
this is the way the Washington Post
handles people who disagree one more
from another Washington Post reporter
this is a guy by the name of Philip bump
and Philip bump uh went on a podcast
called the table podcast where they
asked him about Washington post's
coverage or lack thereof of the hunter
Biden story which is hilarious because
his name is Bump and that's one of the
things one might do with cocaine
what do you take from the text message
to his adult daughter uh Hunter
technician I had to get 50 of my income
to pop I have no idea what that means I
don't I have no idea what that means
well it's it's it's I know it's
circumstantial evidence and you prefer
that what what I have no idea but
doesn't it don't know well I appreciate
your has anybody has anybody asked her I
don't know I don't know don't you think
somebody should ask her okay like I'm
not I just said I don't know and I don't
know what to make of it so I have
nothing to say about it yeah but you say
there's no evidence no evidence but then
there's a text message where he says I
give pop 50 of my money
that's that's evidence okay well what
okay fine fine so evidence I appreciate
you having me on it doesn't it that
something like that
who do you think is important other than
that I'm saying
I don't feel you want me to leave like
just walk out in the middle of this
because that way you can like you can go
is this a standard really this is the
way the Washington Post handles people
who disagree with when I agree to be on
for 45 minutes and then I get on for an
hour and 15. yeah I did after a while I
go thanks for having me
first off I agreed to be out for 45
minutes I'm here for an hour for me dude
you're a quote-unquote journalist all
you have to do is drink yourself to
sleep I've met enough of you people okay
you have nothing better to do the host
did a really nice job there it's like
what is your what is the point of you as
a journalist like do you think it might
be worth asking a follow-up question
he's like ah how are I know what am I a
journalist on a podcast
I just can't take these people